créer un champion mondial de la
transformation écologique c'est
l'ambition du groupe veolia à travers
son au pea sur son rival suez déjà
propriétaire de 29 9% de suez depuis
octobre 2020 veolia a lancé une
opération publique d'achat en juillet
dernier afin d'acquérir les 70 1 %
restants la transaction devrait être
soldées en janvier prochain mais tout
pourrait ne pas se passer comme prévu
car l'union syndicale du groupe suez a
déposé plainte le 22 avril dernier
auprès du parquet national financiers
pour des faits de trafic d'influencé
elle dénonce une opération calculé au
plus haut sommet de l'état et demande sa
suspension immédiate loupé à hostile de
veolia envers suez n'obéit à aucune
logique économique ou industrielle
il apparaît aujourd'hui que cet opéra ne
serait que le fruit de décisions prises
et favoriser au plus haut sommet de
l'état pour dépecer le gant français des
services environnementaux au seul profit
de quelques-uns les syndicats
soupçonnent plus particulièrement le
secrétaire général de l'elysée chez
alexis kohler le pdg de veolia le
président du conseil d'administration d'
angie et le pdg du fonds
d'investissement méridiam de s'être
entendues sur la fusion dans leur
plainte selon la fp les syndicats citent
plusieurs réunions impliquant le
gouvernement il cite aussi
l'intervention d' alexis kohler en
octobre 2020 auprès de représentants
syndicaux l' enquête a été confiée à
l'office central de lutte contre la
corruption et les infractions
financières et fiscales une première
victoire pour les syndicats on ne peut
que se réjouir que la plainte des
syndicats était prise au sérieux par le
pnf qui ouvre une enquête cette enquête
doit faire la lumière sur les collusions
entre le monde politique et le monde des
affaires c'est malheureusement une
spécificité française de l'autre côté
veolia meridiam et angie se refuse à
tout commentaire quant à alexis colère
il est déjà visé par une information
judiciaire hier dans la sphère des
chantiers navals de saint nazaire pour
prise illégale d'intérêt trafic
d'influencé et défauts de déclaration à
la haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique il est soupçonné
d'avoir caché ses liens familiaux avec
des cadres de l'entreprise de msc alors
qu'il aurait favorisé l'entreprise dans
des décisions engageant de l'argent
public sous la houlette d'un emmanuel
macron à leur ministre de l'économie